hey i'm abby and i'm a developer
advocate for google cloud developer
experiences
and i'm nafio from jetbrains
and we're going to walk you through how
to build a cloud run service using a
little plugin in pycharm called cloud
code
cloud code is a plugin that makes your
local development experience with google
cloud services like gke and cloud run
more streamlined and convenient it's
supported for a variety of ides
including pycharm and intellij
not fuel how can everyone get in on the
pycharm and cloud code action well first
you need pycharm installed now to
install cloud code head to the
marketplace by clicking preferences then
plugins and search for cloud code
you might be prompted to restart pie
chart
once that's done cloud code should be
ready
you'll need docker installed and running
in the background to use cloud code
while cloud code automatically installs
command line dependencies like the cloud
sdk for you you might need to manually
install it if you have certain
permissions blocking the install later
in this video i'll show you how to add a
cloud sql database connection to both
your cloud run service and pycharm's
database panel for that step you'll need
to install cloud sql proxy check the
description for more info on how to do
this abby want to show how to get
started with a cloud run sample sure
thing once you install cloud code you'll
notice some new ui in pycharm to the
right there are cloud code specific
panels that align with different google
cloud flows we'll be focusing on cloud
run so i'll open cloud code's cloud run
panel
here you can view your deployed cloud
run services
and right-click them to view their urls
getting started with cloud run has a
slight learning curve if you choose to
build your image with docker with cloud
code you can create a new cloud run
project that comes with a handy docker
file
or build with build packs instead
to create a new project select new
project
go over to cloud code cloud run
and then give it a name
you can then choose between flask or
django for your project we're going to
choose flask and hit create
now the sample is loaded you have a
boilerplate project for flask it's a
simple hello world service
and here's that docker file i mentioned
to run a cloud on surface locally cloud
code comes packaged with a cloud run
emulator
when you run your service locally in the
emulator you get to test and debug your
code in a production-like environment
this samples emulator is already
configured but what if you wanted to add
environment variables or connect those
servers to a cloud sql database you can
edit your configuration and
under advanced revision settings you can
update your services cpu allocation
environment variables
and specify cloud sql database
connections to connect your cloud run
service to a cloud sql database just put
your instance connection name here and
you're good to go in a minute nafio will
walk through how to connect pycharm to a
cloud sql database to make working with
databases easier you can also specify a
service account which is very important
for authenticating your cloud run
service with google cloud apis
and towards the bottom of my run
configuration i can pick my builder i'll
stick with using my docker file but if i
didn't have one i could select build
packs which analyzes your application
structure and determines the best way to
containerize it
but everything is looking good
now i can either debug
or run my service in the emulator i'm
only going to run this service in this
video
but if i were to debug this it would
look exactly like the pycharm debugging
experience you're used to
alright now let's run this
pycharm is now running the application
locally the first time you spin up the
emulator can take a couple minutes but
future runs are much faster now we got a
local url so let's try clicking on it
and boom your app is hosted locally in
the cloud run emulator and logs are
displayed in the output
this surface is ready to deploy to cloud
run but before we do that though
nafil could you talk about pycharm's
database support
yeah pycharm pro comes with integrated
database tools pycharg's databases panel
allows you to seamlessly check your
cloud sql database this lets you check
to see if your code is making the
desired changes in your database to
connect to a cloud sql database from
pycharm you'll need to install and run
the cloud sql proxy from a terminal then
all we need to do is give it the name of
the instance we want to connect to and
the port we want to forward that
connection to this creates a proxy to
our local host on that port after doing
this we can head into our databases tab
and add a database
in this case i'm adding postgres
i've set up a username and password so
i'll put that in now i'll test the
connection
in general it's always good to check
that your connection is working with the
configurations and credentials you've
given it
once we have that set up
we can see what schemas are available to
us
and what tables are available in that
particular schema
that's the quick and easy way to work
with cloud sql databases from pycharm
now i think it's time to deploy our
service
to deploy your service you now need to
edit the deploy configurations
and give it a google cloud project from
here you can set extra configurations
like we did for the emulator everything
seems to be in order i'm building my
image locally with docker but you can
also build in the cloud with cloud build
because we're building this from a
docker file we can hit apply and then
okay now we can press that green play
button and run this this tells pycharm
to start deploying
cloud code is now building and pushing
my container image
and once that's complete we get a
service url and my first service appears
in the cloud run panel
we also get a handy link to the logs of
my deployed service
and congratulations your service is now
running on google cloud anyone can
access it
that was a look at getting started with
cloud run using pycharm and cloud code i
encourage you to install cloud code from
your ides marketplace and if you have
any questions you can reach out to us on
our slack channel
thank you so much for watching if you
want to learn more about how to use
pycharm check out our youtube channel
we're constantly putting out new videos
that will teach you how to use pycharm
and also how we make pie chart